deep in komathansha's rolling hills
little has changed in centuries
but land once farmed here by families is
moving into new hands
not to locals but to multi-billion pound
investment firms
those fields you know
that's generations of hard work to see
it destroyed
just for an investment company to be
able to plant trees to me is is
uh it's just incredibly upsetting
in the tiny village of courty cadnoe
lies frongok farm it was recently bought
by london-based investment company
foresight group which has plans to plant
thousands of trees here but locals fear
swathes of conifers
could damage the very landscape
trees are a good thing and we want to
promote
tree growth what we're looking at is the
wrong trees for ecological and
environmental purposes not only does it
affect the visual and the spatial
enjoyment of this beautiful area
but it really has an impact on everybody
who lives here
mass tree planting is not just an issue
at frongok it's understood around a
dozen farms in wales have been snapped
up by companies outside of the country
it is easy to see the attraction for
outside investors firstly simply owning
the land is obviously a significant
asset secondly they can make money from
timber grown here and thirdly they can
sell carbon credits from the trees they
plant to any company that wants to
offset its carbon footprint
the welsh government wants to plant 86
million trees by the end of this decade
with substantial grants available but it
does admit it is keen to avoid outside
interests buying up welsh land
foresight group told sky news its plans
for new woodlands are an activity which
is recognized by the welsh government as
an important part of the twin fights
against climate change and biodiversity
loss
it added we will be planting a diverse
species mix at frank gok foresight never
plants trees on land that can support
productive commercial food crop growth
the national farmers union in wales
welcomes tree planting schemes but says
they should complement farming not
replace it if you've seen a monoculture
approach to this and a blanket
deforestation that's a fundamental
change that's not what we're looking for
here in wales a fundamental change in
what way to a community well to it well
it's decimation of that community really
isn't it
this aspect of the valley will be
obliterated community concern comes amid
big climate change targets
changing the landscape could be the
price to pay
in order to meet them dan whitehead sky
news in court academy comarthinger